a federal judge is deciding if the Air
National Guardsman accused of stealing
classified documents can be released on
Bill 21-year-old Jack texera appeared in
court yesterday in Massachusetts where
his lawyer argued against keeping him in
jail senior investigative correspondent
Catherine Herridge is in Washington with
more on the arguments Catherine good
morning good morning Nate Federal
prosecutors allege that texera has a
history of using violent and racist
rhetoric they want Tex Sarah to remain
Behind Bars pending trial but his
defense team argued for a supervised
release and texera's own father
testified taxira is accused of leaking
hundreds of pages of classified military
documents and CIA updates including the
war in Ukraine which is why prosecutors
told the judge they believe texera could
take steps to flee the U.S with the help
of a hostile country his lawyer called
those allegations imaginary and argued
that he could be released to the custody
of his father who testified he would be
prepared to turn in his own son should
he violate the terms of the release the
judge pushback against texsera's lawyers
characterizing leaked intelligence about
Ukraine and Russia as quite relevant
finally texaira's lawyers said the
Espionage charges while serious are
non-violent and their client is entitled
to pre-trial release the judge said
he'll issue his ruling at a later date
Gale hmm
Catherine thank you very much